it's actually not my job to answer your
questions are you prepared to call h a
terror group is it possible to have a
rational I've asked you two questions
should a mass stay in power and are they
a terror group you're refusing to answer
either of them that is very telling talk
TV is the only place where you get the
truth you've done a book on poetry
poetry and music for the many I love
poetry we can agree on
that
on TV on Radio and on your smartphone
this is talk
[Music]
TV tonight on Pi Morgan uncensored in
Los Angeles back with a bang and an
unmissable Blockbuster interview the
post office Scandal the Epstein files
the Golden Globes a massive election
year in the UK and the US Wars raging in
Israel and Ukraine so many big stories
big events and who better to talk about
it than Dr Jordan Peterson the man with
one of the biggest brains in the world
tonight he joins me for the hour and
he's
[Music]
uncensored this is Pier Morgan
uncensored well good evening from Los
Angeles welcome to Pi Morgan uncensored
the Golden Globes is one of the biggest
nights in the Hollywood calendar Stars
jetted in last night from across the
world and descended on this city in
their stretched limousines and sparkling
gowns for a glorious celebration of
Tinsel Town's top talent coupled with
enthusiastic Mutual backs slabbing on
stage at least that's the plan Ricky
jaas hosted it in 2020 and famously did
this you'll be pleased to know this is
the last time I'm hosting these Awards
so I don't care anymore um I'm joking I
never did
um NBC clearly don't care either fifth
time so if you win right come up accept
your little award thank your agent and
your God and off
okay well last night after it was taken
off air for a year for bad behavior and
a diversity ra the Golden Globes
returned just down the road from where
I'm sitting and an extraordinary thing
happened the ceremony was so devoid of
the usual political pontificating and
virtue signaling sermons it looks as if
Hollywood might finally have got the
Javas memo even more amazingly Javas
himself who's currently running the
cancel culture Gauntlet once again for
his supposedly unacceptable and
distasteful jokes in his new Netflix
special Armageddon actually won a top
award for it amid the conflict
disruption and a massive year for
elections around the world maybe 2024
has begun with a suggestion just a
suggestion that the woke worm is finally
turning but back in Britain it's the
ordinary people who represent the very
best of our communities who are making
the news and what's happened to the
victims of the post office Scandal is
nothing less than a national outrage
more than 700 post office branch
managers were convicted of false
accounting fraud and theft over a period
of six years but we now know that was
because of faulty software they were
forced to install and use they did
nothing wrong they weren't criminals men
and women who were often the backbone of
their towns and Villages running small
businesses that provide an essential
service for some of the most vulnerable
were hauled over the calls as fraudsters
some were wrongfully sent to prison many
were financially ruined marriages broke
down many collapsed into addiction and
sickness as they lost everything some of
them have since died including four who
took their own lives simply unable to
cope with the appalling smear and strain
of false convictions hanging over them
until the very end yet where is the
accountability for this shameful Fiasco
Paul of venel who was chief executive at
the time wasn't punished for presiding
with such a disgrace instead incredibly
she was awarded one of this country's
finest honors a
CBE that honor for dishonor should as
prime minister Rishi sunak suggested
today be
revoked as for sir Ed Davy who was
postal minister at the time and now
leads the liberal Democrats will he
fobbed off the victims with dismissive
letters saying there'd be no point
meeting to discuss it this is a man who
spends most of his time demanding the
resignation of other public figures he's
done it no fewer than 31 times in the
last few years it's time for s ed to
maybe take his own
medicine there should also be full and
immediate compensation payments to all
those who were wrongly accused and it
shouldn't just come from the British
taxpayer Fujitsu the Japanese firm that
made the faulty it system should be made
to pay too this was a sickening betrayal
of decent hardworking people people the
absolute salt of the earth of this
country and nothing will ever properly
fix the wrong that was done to them but
it's long overdue time that we made a
serious and Swift attempt to rectify the
damage well who better discuss all these
issues and many others facing the world
and the author and psychologist Dr
Jordan Peterson Jordan great to have you
back on uncentered I may I wish you a
very happy New
Year same to you pierce and thanks for
the
invitation let me ask you do you believe
in New Year's resolutions do you have
any are they
pointless no I I don't think a vision is
ever pointless I think it's a good idea
and the idea of a New Year's resolution
is very ancient idea you know you can
you can trace it all the way back to
ancient
Mesopotamia so it's the death of the old
that's the old year often symbolized by
an old man and then the birth of
something new and you see a conjunction
between that and the Christmas
celebration as well
and so when you have the opportunity to
start again you can start fresh you can
lay a New Vision on the world and that's
how we cope with the world is by laying
a vision on it consciously or
unconsciously better to do it
consciously so there's any number of
reasons for New Year's
resolutions do you have
any well I make plans all the time so I
don't specifically have New Year's
resolutions per se um I've built that
process of making plans and generating
Visions into my life for a very very
long time uh we developed software to
help people do that there's a site
called selfauthoring.com that helps
people elaborate out a future vision for
example and so it's something I do on a
very regular
basis the other thing that's happened to
you in the last uh since we last spoke
to each other is you become a
grandfather again a daughter Michaela
gave birth a little Boy George and
there's a lovely picture that our
viewers are now seeing of all of you
together let me ask you Jordan you've
spoken a lot about being a father about
parenting what's the difference between
being a father and a
grandfather well I think what what's the
colloquial way of dealing with that I as
a grandparent you have all the pleasures
and none of the pitfalls essentially you
can stand back farther you can be just
more pure fun as well because the
primary responsibility for disciplinary
interventions at least in principle has
been devolved to your children and then
it's very interesting to watch them do
that too and it's reasonable for you to
take a back seat because well it's now
your children's responsibility to deal
with their children and you can stand in
the background and be good fun and wise
counsel and that's a very good
deal the the interesting thing is what's
happening I think to the the woke
world if you like which has been a sort
of new form of fascism allbe ironically
driven by people who would say fascism
is their number one enemy um I watched
the Golden Globes last night for example
uh an event that was taken off air last
year in a row about uh racial bias and
so on in the institution that puts it on
uh and it came back on really
fascinating to me I watched the whole
thing for three hours no political
speeches no virtue signaling no
grandstanding people basically did what
Ricky Jes told them to do three years
ago which is get up you know thank your
agent and and sit down and just
celebrate making movies or TV shows um
is this a sign Jordan do you think I I
felt that there is a movement going on
now of a real backlash from perhaps a
majority that's been silent till now has
just said enough and that even Hollywood
has woken up to the reality that people
who watch the movies and TV show they
don't want to hear this stuff all the
time well we put politics first and
foremost and partly the reason we did
that was because any higher AIMS in some
ways collapsed I suppose that's part and
parcel of the famous death of God if
what's highest spiritually and
transcendentally disappears then
something else steps up to take its
place and in our society that's either
been a istic bent that's very powerful
or politicking in general and the
problem with that is that you're
supposed to Render unto Cesar what is
Caesar and unto God what is God gods and
the mistake that entertainers make is
that they regard what they do as mere
entertainment Hollywood stars and all
the people who were involved in
producing the narratives that entice and
and and uh compel us they're serving a
master whose far higher than anything
merely political and when they bend
their art to serve a political Master
they distort the higher to the lower to
their own detriment and people aren't so
so that's the philosophical problem with
an artist becoming political it's art
supersedes Politics the art should never
be subordinated to serve the political
because then it gets not only does it
get propagandistic it gets dull and
contemptible
no one cares what a star thinks about
Trump especially when what they what
they have to say about Trump can be said
just as coherently by your demented
neighbor but the fundamental problem is
that we don't understand that the story
is the thing and these Artists movie
stars who are so privileged and often so
talented and and and have this wonderful
opportunity to shape the culture from
which politics is Downstream have
forgotten how sacred you might say their
mission truly is and some of that's even
a false humility you know I suppose many
Hollywood stars believe that their
luxurious and privileged life isn't paid
for by the grueling necessity of having
to make a movie which is more something
like a great adventure and so they feel
guilty and feel that they have to serve
something real but the problem with that
is is that
well who said the political was real
first of all and second there is
absolutely nothing wrong with being a
profound story teller in fact apart from
being a profound artist and perhaps
profound spiritually I can't think of
anything that is more clearly dedicated
to the highest possible cause and when
we forget that we destroy art and we
destroy the people who make it and we
undermine our culture and it's possible
as you pointed out given this pullback
let's say at the glob at the Golden
Globes that the storytellers are
starting to realized that subordinating
their venture to the idiot political
especially a victim victimizer narrative
which is the lowest form of the
political is counterproductive in every
possible way including financially hence
Disney yeah I mean and also I was struck
by the jux deposition of the Globes with
the Rich and Famous turning up and
celebrating their art which is great and
I totally agree with you that the art
actually is a is a great calling was
also a great escapism when times are
difficult you know in the middle of a
pandemic and cost of living crisis and
Wars raging again in Europe and so on to
to be able to escape into the world of
television or movies is actually really
important for people it's good for
people's mental health um but back in
Britain we've had this Dreadful Scandal
involving people who are not rich and
famous they're just ordinary hardworking
members of the public who were running
little post office branches delivering
the mail to people and because of a
faulty Japanese uh computer system
suddenly hundreds and hundreds of them
were accused of fraud because the
computers were malfunctioning and they
were in many cases put in prison they
were all given criminal convictions many
suffered appalling mental health many
lost everything they had four of them
committed suicide uh an absolutely
appalling Scandal and yet here we are 20
years later with it still unresolved no
accountability the woman who ran the
post of the time got honored for her
work not punished the senior politician
whose job it was to oversee this was so
dismissive that he's now being lambasted
by the victims but remains a leader of a
major party in Britain and you've got
this Japanese company Fujitsu who have
seen no uh reason so far to offer any
Financial compens ation to these poor
people what do you make of that
Scandal well the first thing I would say
is that the rush that we're all engaged
in to automate
everything means that we can automate
our willful blindness and our stupidity
and generally willful blindness and
stupidity are in more plentiful Supply
than wisdom and we are in terrible
danger of automating tyranny and and and
what yeah well willful blindness is the
best way to put it no all these systems
that we're developing are essentially
equivalent to the unconscious mind
they're they're the implicit structures
that shape our world and you see this
making itself manifest everywhere so
your country the UK is completely
covered with closed circuit TV cameras
right we're automating we're we're
risking automating a kind of tyranny
that's absolutely unimaginable and the
problem with that is that especially
once you get AI involved you actually
don't know what's being automated you
don't know what biases and errors are
being built into the system and you're
foregoing the possibility that those
Accused by such systems will be able to
hold someone human capable of suffering
for their sins let's say responsible for
the for the Injustice this is an
unbelievably uh major source of current
threat you know I've been using chat GPT
and Elon musk's grock as research
assistants continually over the last few
months and they're unbelievably
intelligent systems and remarkably
helpful as research assistant it's like
having a team of competent Master's
students in multiple disciplines more or
less at your back and call but they also
lie constantly they and they're biased
probably because they've been trained on
a surfite of recent Publications
politically biased in a way that's
absolutely unconscionable and we
genuinely risk automating our proclivity
towards slavish slavishness and tyranny
and that's going to become a much worse
problem uh it's going to threaten us
digitally because our digital identities
are already controlled by quasi or half
automated machines and it's going to
threaten us directly as it did in the
case of these postal workers so you know
you know in increasingly you can't move
from country to Country without going
through a facial recognition system no
you're monitored by systems that will
increasingly be beyond our understanding
and beyond our control and we have to
step so carefully to put those systems
into place properly that it's hardly
imaginable and we don't have the legal
framework even in place now to ensure
that that's going to be possible your
digital self and mine as well have
virtually no protection and you as you
extend yourself out into the virtual
world there that is you just as your
reputation can be destroyed virtually
you're extended now into this virtual
space and who has ownership over the you
that exists in this virtual space is by
no means
clear we're here thanks for joining us
you're with talk TV on TV on radio
online run your smart speaker as well
criminals to using XL Bully dogs as
weapons to threaten others no matter how
well trained most dog owners will tell
you a dog can turn you know what I love
about to today we do it all sunak sella
scon I rather like David Cameron I don't
sort of bear him any ill will because he
delivered the referendum that he said he
would deliver the tor's love a scrap you
can almost see this coming round the
tracks with sella bravman she's heading
up one side and richy soon at the other
the police are pro Palestine that is
just not right you swearing Al in the
police to act without fear or favor the
co inquir seems to have turned into a
sort of pantomim there's not really any
substance to it it's hard to know
whether it's a fce or a
tragedy the amount of time it's taken
the number of illegal migrants currently
sent by us to Rwanda zil the amount of
money it's cost we're saying what are we
saying it's cost about 140 million1 140
million so far so40 million so far
result nil absolutely nil
are we only going to be trusting sources
like meta and Google where is our
unbiased news going to come from Kell in
winter is
cold that is from the Jeremy Corbin book
Kevin O Sullivan is the worst presenter
on talk TV sitting on his fat ass
talking for a liit if you're walking
towards me and you're a vegan should
have a great big orange sticker over
here saying watch out vegan's
about the weirdest plank that we've had
in three years hundreds and hundreds of
mice in a box which he walks into a
branch of McDonald MC mous man MC mous
man MC M man he should be easy enough to
catch this guy shouldn't he I mean he's
got house full of
mice this is a major Summit President
Biden decided this was important after
watching a Tom Cruz
film sunak and the current conservative
government are not conservative why
don't you leave that party and come to
one that actually shares your ideology
this has been a party political
broadcast on behalf of reform okay party
hi just kids think all they have to do
is take pictures of everything just shut
down Tik Tok problem s this is really
unfair what what what's unfair if it's
on camera we're not doing interviews yes
I'm going to do I'm going you're going
to Res yes CU I cannot continue my work
when I say I am God I'm not joking did
you feel Elvis was controlling I've been
answering your question you answer mine
it's actually not my job to answer your
questions are you prepared to call ter
group is it possible to have a rational
I've asked you two questions should a m
stay in power and are they a terror
group you're refusing to answer either
of them that is very telling talk TV
it's the only place where you get the
truth you've done a book on poetry
poetry and music for the many I love
poetry we can agree on
that
[Music]
on the on the US election I've been here
now for 10 days or so in America you can
feel the heat building to the Iowa
caucuses next week and then New
Hampshire primary and so on uh this is
the real kind of Kickstart for the US
election um I can also feel the
temperature on both sides of this debate
ratcheting up uh it seems to me that
there's no short-term solution to the
toxic tribalism that infests not just
the American political system but the UK
political system in fact political
systems everywhere what do you feel
about that what what is your what's your
sort of prediction for how you think
this election May unravel
here well I think the danger of
artificial intelligence generated false
news skewing the election results is
extremely high because you can imagine
and I can't even see how this won't
happen you can imagine the unbelievable
utility of a well-timed fake video
account of trump or Biden doing
something clearly reprehensible timed
mere hours before an election and I see
at the moment absolutely no way that we
can protect ourselves against such
things I think for me at a deeper level
the solution to the problem that you're
describing is a psycholog olical
solution that is
inevitable in light of our increased
technological
power people are going to have to
understand more
consciously that the errors that they
propagate morally the acts of willful
blindness pretending that they're doing
something other than they are doing
morally grandstanding outright lying or
avoiding the truth with all this
technological power at our hands the
cataclysmic consequences of those moral
errors are radically magnified and I I
don't see that there's an alternative to
that as we get better at doing good
things faster we simultaneously get
better at doing bad things faster and at
a wider scale and you know I concluded
decades ago and this is partly why I
stayed as a psychologist rather than say
pursuing a political career is that
we've always known in the west that the
weight of the world rests on our
individual shoulders right the Central
story of the West is that each person is
to take up their cross and carry it
uphill and that that's a Divine calling
and that the fate of the world in some
sense depends on that and we're going to
see Pierce in the next 30 Years we're
going to see and it might be a lot
faster than that just exactly how true
that is as the evidence for the world
disrupting consequences of our
hypothetically trivial errors start to
become increasingly manifest increasing
and rapidly manifest lay lay out the
underlying archetypal structure of
reality you know the endless battle
between good and evil and the most
profound commentators on such battle
have always concluded that the
fundamental line is drawn in the human
soul and if you want to get the Demons
of the world under control you better
start with the demons in your own skull
and if you don't think that's enough to
keep you busy that just means you
haven't looked inside with enough what
courage and P perspicacity there's
plenty of disorder in your own soul to
occupy yourself with for the rest of
your life and this is something uh we're
either going to learn this
voluntarily consciously and wisely or
we're going to be Beat to Death by our
own stupidity and that's going to happen
quickly in many many ways you can see it
unfolding well you can see it unfolding
around us
now so two questions the US election can
Donald Trump win and would it be a good
thing for America and the world if he
does
win well I think he can win assuming
that he'll be put on the ballot as far
as I've been able to tell and God only
knows how reliable the polls are and
generally not very because the questions
are usually biased
unconscionably he he's certainly popular
enough to win I don't see another
candidate emerging on the Republican
side at the moment who poses a threat
there are some interesting people
running that's for sure it looks to me
like DeSantis is a pretty competent
character and VC ramaswami is at minimum
very interesting and bright and quite
the disruptive Force um on the Democrat
side you know Dean Phillips who almost
no one knows about and who the Democrats
are doing what would you say everything
they can to to keep it that way he's an
interesting alternative to Biden I don't
think Kennedy has a chance although
there are some things about him I like I
think Trump could win will that be good
it depends on what he does if he wins it
depends on the manner in which the
victory takes place it depends on
whether or not the people on the more
conservative side of the spectrum are
able to extend a welcoming hand to those
who were more on the Progressive side
and it certainly depends on whether
those on the Progressive side are
willing to dispense with some of the
ideological stupidity that possesses
them that is generating an endless
sequence of unnecessary culture War know
the the left in particular has become
100% preoccupied with the most
pathological possible political
narrative which is essentially a victim
victimizer story that you can understand
every every element of social
interaction among humans from Marriage
upwards to the political in terms of
who's got the power who's the oppressed
and there's nothing in that but an
endless recipe for not only for the most
bitter of Soul devouring resentments but
for the application of any form of
Vengeance imaginable it's I it's I can't
imagine this something that possesses
the universities as well there is
nothing nothing more toxic than a victim
victimizing narrative and that certainly
possesses the radical left in particular
to the nth degree and there's nothing in
that but disaster so you know it's part
and parcel of what we've been discussing
there's going to be very rapid change
not least on the Electoral front in the
upcoming year and how that goes will
depend on how people conduct themselves
and and ever more so so we can pray that
we're terrified enough of the potential
negative consequences and enticed Enough
by the potential positive consequences
to walk ever more
carefully we'll see yeah if you're if
you have big toys you better be a big
boy and we don't have big toys we have
giant toys and they will stomp us into
the ground unless we're wise enough to
guide them
properly you know the fascinating thing
about Trump for example is I always say
to people I've known him a long time and
know him very well he's got the thinnest
skin of any person in public life he
reacts to absolutely everything and goes
to death G one with in a heartbeat um
but he also has the thickest skin he can
soak up stuff that would crush any other
political figure in history in seconds
this is a guy facing nearly a hundred
criminal charges and yet all that's done
is actually make him more popular I mean
it it's we are into completely Uncharted
Territory with Trump as a as a political
figure aren't
we well I don't think the Democrats
could have done a better job of keeping
the name of trump alive if they would
have planned to do that and it's
certainly possible that in some ways
they did plan to do that because the
scuttlebutt among the political
theorists that pass for wise men among
the Democrats is that well if Trump is
the candidate then Biden can beat him
it's like well not necessarily I
wouldn't bet the farm on that although
that's probably already occurred
and you know Trump
is canny enough to know that in some
real way all publicity is good publicity
and it's certainly the case that the
Democrat persecution of trump and I
think that's the right term has kept him
alive and has also cast him so
perversely in the role of victim that
the Democrats themselves are always what
would you say trumpeting as being allied
with it's it's an unbelievably demented
move on the Strategic side you know my
sense was if Biden would have taken a
careful look at the Abraham Accords
which he certainly should have because
then we wouldn't be in the situation
we're in right now in relationship to
Israel let's say he could have given
Trump a medal clapped him on the back
said good job mate and maybe he would
have ridden off his into the sunset now
that would have meant that Democrats
would have had to contend with someone
like disantis let's say who's at minimum
hyper competent and I don't think that
was in the cards so instead they
determined to play idiot political games
not like those aren't well known on the
Republican side and they rais Trump from
the dead and they do that
continually
so well so I I think personally and this
is just a guess because what do I know I
think that the most likely outcome is
that Trump is the next president that's
what it looks like to me so I think
that's you know unfortunate I think I
think that that that could he's so
divisive hey that's the problem yeah
yeah I mean I I you know it was
interesting because when I did the
Celebrity Apprentice the first series of
that back in 2008 I saw Trump across a
boardroom table for three hours a night
for about six week weeks and you get to
know somebody pretty well actually
because a lot of it didn't get aired if
he showed even an ounce of the empathy
that he showed to people then if he
showed more of the of the humor without
being vicious if he showed less of the
punching everyone in the face and more
of occasionally putting a metaphorical
arm around people I think the perception
of Trump would change dramatically but
he he seems to think the only way to be
a political leader is to be a kind of
swaggering trash talking very aggressive
person and I think that's a shame it's a
shame for him and it's a shame for those
like me who see a lot of good in Trump
he's been you know he was very good to
me when I left America left CNN I went
back to Britain I can count on one hand
the number of American people uh in the
business if you like who stayed in touch
with me Trump did he ranged me quite
regularly to check how I was doing could
he help you know didn't need to do that
so he has got these qualities it's just
I don't see much evidence of it of him
as a political leader he's taken a
different
path well I would say part of that is a
consequence of the fact that the radical
leftists have given it compassion and
empathy a bad name you know and so
because Trump is standing against
especially the
radicals he's being put in a position
where he more or less de facto has to
stand against that kind of smothering
quasi maternal devouring sympathy that's
part and parcel of being allied with the
victims and so part of that's an
ideological problem I would also say
that I believe that there has been no
political figure certainly in my living
memory with the possible exception of
Richard Nixon who's being vilified more
thoroughly and also more more falsely
than Trump and I would point to the
idiot conclusion of Russian collusion
especially with regards to the hunter
Biden laptop as evidence in that regard
you know I mean Trump has no shortage of
flaws let's say a statement that can be
said of all of us but apart from vicious
criticism with regard to those faults
there's been an absolute surfite of
devastating criticism and persecution
for faults that are not real and you
know it isn't obvious to me how much a
person can take without starting to feel
continually embattled you know I've
certainly had to fight against the
proclivity to cease turning the other
cheek let's say with regards to those
who regard themselves as my enemies
because if you're gone after enough you
tend to think that the only the best
defense is a good offense let's say and
yeah it's very difficult to plot Your
Way Forward against those kinds of odds
now Trump did go into the White House as
an outsider both on the Republican and
the Democrat front and he has faced no
shortage of impediments and it's a hell
of a lot to ask of someone to take all
that with good graces and he's certainly
done better than he might have in that
regard guard I mean he's still in the
race for example now you might say well
if you want to be president you better
be the guy that has that kind of largess
of spirit and fair enough
but but you know let him who is without
sin cast the first stone let's say right
um he's an old guy you know and he's
bombastic
and and he's under a lot of pressure and
so
and all the lies that have been
generated to Blacken his name have made
him a worse
man at least in his public facing image
than he might otherwise have been and I
can't help but see in that also a kind
of Nefarious underhanded plan if you
can't defeat your opponent fair and
square on the field of vision let's say
or compassion then you can do everything
you can to back them into a corner and
provoke them into doing something
reprehensible so that you can block in
their name and it's certainly the case
that the Democrats have done absolutely
everything they possibly could to do
that say with regard to January 6th
while simultaneously taking no
responsibility whatsoever for the
widespread rioting that accompanied for
example the black lives matter
movement
we're here thanks for joining us you're
with talk TV on TV on radio online we on
your smart speaker as well you know what
I love about talk today we do it all
sunak sella
scon I rather like David Cameron I don't
sort of bear him any ill will because he
delivered the referendum that he said he
would deliver the tor's love a scrap you
can almost see this coming around the
tracks with sella bravman she's heading
up one side and richy soon at the other
the police are pro Palestine that is
just not right you swearing o in the
police to act without fear or favor the
co inquiry seems to have turned into a
sort of pantomim there's not really any
substance to it it's hard to know
whether it's a fce or a tragedy there
needs to be one human per machine to
come and rectify beeps and the clanks
and when it goes wrong unexpected item
in bagging area I know are we only going
to be trusting sources like meta and
Google where is our unbiased news going
to come from
at Gram was president of the Cambridge
Union which is the rubbish version of
being president of the Oxford
Union Kevin O Sullivan is the worst
presenter on talk TV sitting on his fat
ass talking for living if you're walking
towards me and you're a vegan you have a
great big orange sticker over here
saying watch out vegans about Twitter
you sons of can you please reinstate my
account thank you this is a major Summit
President Biden decided this was
important after watching a Tom Cruz
kids think all they have to do is take
pictures of everything just shut down
Tik Tok problem solved when I say I am
God I'm not joking did you feel Elvis
was controlling I've been answering your
question you answer mine it's actually
not my job to answer your question are
you prepared to call h a terror group is
it possible to have a
rational talk TV it's the only place you
get the
truth
[Music]
this is talk
TV what's your prediction for the UK
election you've been quite scathing
about Sakia stama but the polls show at
the moment certainly uh if the election
happens in the in the Autumn it seems
likely that he is heading to uh some
kind of Victory what do you think that
would mean for Britain and do the
conservatives have any
stopping
that I think it'll be
catastrophic I I believe that labor like
the Socialist parties in Canada is
absolutely overwhelmed by the diversity
equity and inclusivity victim victimizer
narrative types and that even if starmer
himself has any sense which I doubt the
probability that his indans will lay
waste to the UK is it's certain in my
estimation there's so much behind the
scene tyrannizing going on in the name
of hypothetical utopian progress that
it's almost unimaginable I mean the
cctvs in the ules zones are a great
example of that and everything that's
happened in London under sadik Khan
who's like poster boy for ideologically
addled globalist utopians and if the
labor gets in and I can understand why
the citizens of the UK are hungry for a
change if labor gets in it's like
Venezuela here we come I I think it'll
be I think at minimum the UK will
probably manage to overtake Canada as
worst performing developed country over
the next four decades if they're foolish
enough to elect a labor government and
that's quite AOW that's quite a what
would you say an opponent to overcome
given the state of our leadership in
Canada yeah it is what are your thoughts
uh Jordan about the two Wars still
raging Ukraine and Russia and of course
Israel and its war in Gaza against
Hamas well I think Ukraine is great news
for the arms manufacturers and the
military industrial complex and that's I
think that's really 90% of the issue
right there I mean it's it's been in
their interest and I say this without
cynicism by the way it's been in their
interest since the demise of the Cold
War to insist upon the positioning of
Russia as the dire enemy of the West I
mean first of all if you're a military
supplier it's your job to be paranoid
and to look for enemies and there's some
utility in that right I mean that's part
of being wise as serpents let's say but
it also means that there's constant
pressure from extremely well healed
individuals those that run the
military-industrial complex to Dam all
potential Peace Accords with faint
praise and to constantly agitate on the
side of war and preparation thereof
and UK the war in Ukraine is a bonanza
for the military-industrial complex and
that's a complete bloody catastrophe we
had a chance especially in the 90s and
in the 2000s for that matter to make a
longstanding peace with Russia not an
easy thing to do especially in the face
of China um and we we burned up that
opportunity like the fools that we are
and here we are with that with regards
to Israel and and Hamas
well a war occurs when people can't
agree and no one we certainly can't
agree on the facts of the matter at hand
with regard to the conflict in Israel
Isel my sense is most fundamentally that
it's been hyper convenient for the
radical islamists especially those in
Iran to have Hamas and the Palestinians
suffer greatly and continually so that
they can be a constant go in the S of
Israel and the US and so we've stepped
right into that as well um what's the
solution well you know I'd be a fool to
offer one wouldn't I because there's
been a plethora of Solutions offered
with regards to Israel and the
Palestinians over the last six decades
and very little progress has been made
on that front and I think the reason for
that is that there are incredibly
entrenched
interests in whose interest it is to
prolong and make as bloody as possible
this conflict and so there's no hope for
peace under those circumstances and for
the Islamic fundamentalists so-called
Islamic fundamentalists who are
fostering the conflict what's a few
hundred thousand or million Palestinian
lives you know doesn't hurt them if all
those innocent people die so that's a
dreadful
situation
um if I was in Israel's shoes I suppose
I would likely do much the same as they
are doing with one possible Koda which
is that as Israel becomes more
successful on the military front which
is highly
likely the swing in popular opinion is
likely to
increasingly go against them because
it's a lot easier to trumpet moral
virtue by siding with the hypothetical
victims than it is to celebrate the
accomplishment of the conquerors and so
I'm afraid that one likely outcome for
Israel is that they win militarily but
lose
strategically however we'll see U one of
the things I'm very happy about however
and this is really a miracle and it's
one that we should be very attentive to
is that despite the rising temperature
and costs of this conflict the Abraham
Accords which established a certain
degree of peace between Israel and a
number of states who were previously in
a state of enmity that Accord has held
and that that's the best news on the
geopolitical front that I can think of
in the last 50 years you know there is
some real possibility still that Israel
and its neighbors could enter into a
long-standing and productive peace and
God we could all pray for that because
that would be the best possible outcome
for everyone involved I'm certain that
Iran Iran does not believe that that
pathway is in their interest and so
they're going to do everything they can
not only to Foster this war which is
what they have been doing but also to
fund and ferment all the protests that
have been racking the Western World in
support hypothetical support of
Hamas we're here thanks for joining us
you're with talk TV on TV on radio
online we on your smart speaker as well
criminals to using XL Bully dogs as
weapons to threaten others no matter how
well trained most dog owners will tell
you a dog can turn you know what I love
about to today we do it all sunak sella
scon I rather like David Cameron I don't
sort of bear him any ill will because he
delivered the referendum that he said he
would deliver the tor's love a scrap you
can almost see this coming round the
tracks with sella bravman she's heading
up one side and richy soon at the
other the police are pro Palestine that
is just not right you swear an o in the
police to act without fear or favor
the co inquiry seems to have turned into
a sort of pantomim there's not really
any substance to it it's hard to know
whether it's a fce or a
tragedy the amount of time it's taken
the number of illegal migrants currently
sent by us to Rwanda zil the amount of
money it's cost we're saying what are we
saying it's cost about 140 million 140
million so far so40 million so far
results nil absolutely nil are we only
going to be trusting sources like meta
and Google where is our unbiased news to
come from Kell in winter is
cold that is from the Jeremy Corbin book
Kevin O Sullivan is the worst presenter
on talk TV sitting on his fat ass
talking for liit if you're walking
towards me and you're a vegan she have a
great big orange sticker over here
saying watch out vegan's
about the weirdest plank that we've had
in three years hundreds and hundreds of
mice in a box which he walked into a
branch of McDonald MC Mouse man M man M
he should be easy enough to catch this
guy shouldn't he I mean he's got house
full of
mice this is a major Summit President
Biden decided this was important after
watching a Tom Cruz
film sunac and the current conservative
government are not conservative why
don't you leave that party and come to
one that actually shares your ideology
this has been a party political
broadcast on behalf of the reform UK
party
hi kids think all they have to do is
take pictures of everything just shut
down Tik Tok problem solved this is
really unfair what what what's unfair if
it's on camera we're not doing
interviews yes I'm going to do you're
going to Res yes cuz I cannot continue
my work when I say I am God I'm not
joking did you feel Elvis was
controlling I've been answering your
question you answer mine it's actually
not my job to answer your questions are
you prepared to call Ham a terror group
is it possible to a rational I've asked
you two questions should aass stay in
power and are there a terror group
you're ref Ching to answer either of
them that is very telling talk TV is the
only place where you get the truth
you've done a book on poetry poetry and
music for the many I love poetry we can
agree on
[Music]
that let's end on a more positive note
uh Jordan um I could talk to you all day
in fact one day I want to do that it
would be fascinating um you've got an
extraordinary mind and you have such an
extraordinary take on all these things
um but let's talk about you and what
your plans are for 2024 I know you got a
a tour you have your Academy and you
have a new
book yes I'm finishing up what I think
will be two books um the first one is
called we who wrestle with God and it's
going to be an analysis of the
fundamental stories of the western world
and so that really means a Biblical
analysis one book is going to focus on
the Old Testament and another the other
on the New Testament and I'm finishing
those up now that'll constitute the
content for the tour that my wife and I
are going on with some special guests
including Jonathan Paso that will run
from February through May um 51 cities
across the United States and then off to
Central and South America and I'm very
much excited about doing that and
recording it and releasing those
recordings live the reason this is so
important Pierce is
because our world depends on Stories
the the Integrity of our psyches is
predicated on the unity and
functionality of the stories that guide
our perceptions and our emotions and our
social stability is predicated on the
sharing of a universal narrative that's
what it means for a culture to be United
in belief and commitment and conviction
and For Better or Worse the uniting
stories of the West are those derived
from the judeo-christian tradition and
we've
lost contact with them we've we've
sought off the branch that we sit on and
part of the reason for that is that
in some way we never really understood
the stories but we willing to act as if
or believe that they were true but we're
now at a point where partly because of
the conflict between the scientific mind
and the religious mind we not only have
to believe we have to understand and
what I'm trying to do is to make that
understanding possible I'm writing as
deeply as I can about the stories that
guide us and I hope to bring what I've
been privileged to investigate to as
wide an audience as possible I'm also
going to do a gospel seminar with many
of the same thinkers that I conducted
The Exodus seminar with in April for the
same reason and so I'm extremely excited
about that I I can't really imagine
doing anything more interesting or
having a privilege that's greater than
having the opportunity to make what I
know public during this tour as I said a
tour of 50 cities very extensive so and
then in
February I'm doing a soft launch with my
daughter of Peterson Academy which is
our attempt to rectify the abysmal
situation that modern institutions of
higher education have landed themselves
in and to provide the opportunity for
people all over the world to obtain a
high quality General University level
education very efficiently hopefully
enjoyably and at a low cost I would say
we're going to drop the price of a
bachelor's degree by
95% and I can't imagine anything being
timed better than that especially in the
aftermath of the absolute catastrophe
that the presidents of upan MIT and
Harvard have made of their uh Associated
institutions yeah I mean we haven't
touched on that but just quickly what
what was your view of that it looked to
me like finally the chickens came home
to roost with the people that led those
colleges who've been basically attacking
Free Speech now for a number of
years
well I when I watched it I watched it in
jaw dropped amazement I felt well what
this is the testimony in DC of the three
University presidents I thought two
things I thought it's a complete bloody
miracle that these people who've been
clamoring for the Restriction of free
speech on the basis of Oppression and
harm can't admit
that c calls for the genocide of Jews no
matter how arguably tangential don't
violate these incredibly restrictive
Free Speech codes which they themselves
have been screeching about like mad
harpies for decades so that was just a
bloody Miracle of blind stupidity and it
was a catastrophe as far as I was
concerned that it characterized
particularly MIT and Harvard because
those were great places and then to Ally
that with the implicit presumption as
they did that it was self-evident that
the moral stance that those same
presidents took would be met with by the
general public with nothing but open arm
depreciation was also an indication of
absolutely how absolutely demen Ed and
and self deluding the universities have
become and I say that apart from my
financial interest in making Peterson
Academy work let's say and my moral
interest as well I say that with no
satisfaction whatsoever I worked at
Harvard for six years and I loved it it
was a great place and the halfwit
Pharisees scribes and lawyers have you
know wormed their way in with their
idiot ideological moral I in and
devastated those institutions you know
and people like Bill Amman who sort of
led the charge along with Christopher
rufo with regard to Claudine gay the
president of Harvard they've started to
wake up to How Deep The Rot goes but you
know they've just barely scraped the
surface so many of our institutions of
Higher Learning including those devoted
to the hypothetically scientific
Endeavor have become corrupted to the
point where replacement is like likely
the only possible way forward you know
like could Harvard find its way once
again well maybe if you did what Elon
Musk did when he took over Twitter and
fired
95% of the administrators and a fair
number of the faculty but who are you
going to get to replace them and who's
going to do that no parallel
institutions are the name of the game
now and you see that with the University
of Austin to see it with Ralston College
in Savannah and that's what we're going
to try to do with Peterson
Academy all the quality at 12th the
price and hopefully a limited amount of
ideological
moralizing we have great professors man
we've got 30 professors who've already
taped courses so I love the uh I love
the ambition for this uh Jordan I've got
to leave it there I don't want to but
we've run out of time thank you so much
for joining me a perfect way to start be
Morgan censored uh for 2024 I wish you
as I said a very happy New Year all the
best with your your expanding family and
I hope to catch up with you again
soon thanks Pierce it's always a
pleasure to talk to
you thanks Jord great to see you well
that's it for me whatever you're up to
keep it unsensitive good
[Music]
night
we're here thanks for joining us you're
with talk TV on TV on radio online on
your smart speaker as well they have
made a statement condemning Hamas we
expect to see the crown revisit Harry's
anti-semitic Halloween costume criminals
to using XL Bully dogs as weapons to
threaten others no matter how well
trained most dog owners will tell you a
dog can turn you know what I love about
sport today we do it all sunak sella
scon I rather like David Cameron I don't
sort of bear him any ill will because he
delivered the referendum that he said he
would deliver the Israelis are very
conciliatory all they want is to be
recognize the timing of this hamus
attack comes because there was the
expectation there was going to be a deal
on to normalizing relations with Saudi
Arabia the Tories love a scrap you can
almost see this coming round the tracks
with sella bravman she's heading up one
side and soon at the other reshuffles
usually very dull this one had booster
Rockets attached to it certainly the
tone has shifted in terms of what Ry
suak has done the question now is what
he does next the police are pro
Palestine that is just not right you
swear an oath in the police to act
without fear or favor the co inquiry
seems to have turned into a sort of
pantomim there's not really any
substance to it it's hard to know
whether it's a fce or a tragedy talk TV
has spoken exclusively to a member of
the Blade Runners do you have a message
for or Sadi Khan we're not stopping
until you
stop the amount of time it's taken the
number of illegal migrants currently
sent by us to Rwanda zil the amount of
money it's cost we're saying what are we
saying it's cost about 140 million 140
million pound so far so40 million so far
results nil absolutely nil are we only
going to be trusting sources like meta
and Google where is our unbiased news
going to come from Kell in winter is
cold
that is from the Jeremy Corbin book
Kevin O Sullivan is the worst presenter
on talk TV sitting on his fat ass
talking for AIT if you're walking
towards me and you're a vegan should
have a great big orange sticker over
here saying watch out vegans
about the weirdest plank that we've had
in three years hundreds and hundreds of
mice in a box which he walked into a
branch of McDonald MC mous man MC mous
man MC he should be easy enough to catch
this guy shouldn't he I mean he's got
house full of
this is a major Summit President Biden
decided this was important after
watching a Tom Cruz film